mercedes presents the new s-class and it
sets new standards in terms of both
technology and comfort the latest
addition is available with a short or
long wheelbase you can choose between
one diesel engine and two gasoline units
generating between 190 and 335 kilowatts
of power
there's also a hybrid option
creating a new s-class is always a big
challenge explains head designer gordon
wagner there's also responsibility
because the s-class is the ultimate
expression of the brand
as ever there's luxury galore
the car simply oozes class and quality
the panel in front of the driver is
digital and displayed on a large screen
a panoramic glass roof translates into a
very spacious feel while the
electronically adjustable seats leave
nothing to be desired in terms of
comfort
the subtle changes from its predecessor
and other models will be immediately
apparent to eagled eyed experts however
the new car is a bit lighter he notes
there are fewer buttons and of course
the big displays
why take second best with the s-class
we put the most powerful version through
its paces the s 500 v8 with a 4.6 liter
displacement and 335 kilowatts of power
the luxury sedan makes the dash to 100
kilometers per hour in a sporty 4.8
seconds and can accelerate with ease up
to 250 k's
official fuel consumption is 8.6 liters
per 100 kilometers
and there's certainly no shortage of
assists magic body control is the apt
name for an intelligent suspension
system
mercedes is the only marquee to feature
active suspension families of stop
explains stereo cameras are used to
detect holes or bumps in the road
the system then guides the wheels over
these irregularities each wheel
individually
this keeps the form of the vehicle on
the same level the car can absorb up to
20 centimeters difference in height
ironing out any bumps
customers will also have the highest
expectations on the visual front where
the s-class has at times divided opinion
proportions are crucial for the head
designer mercedes has classic rear-wheel
drive proportions he says the new
s-class has an even longer hood so that
the car sits even more on the rear axle
mercedes emphasizes that with its
hallmark dropping line which falls away
at the back and the undercut the result
are these wonderfully bold flanks
and the traditional star on top of the
radiator is also crucial of course it
stands for the s-class and for a
125-year heritage mercedes has reworked
it for the next generation first it's
almost twice the size and it's become
more three-dimensional and exudes a lot
more status
then there's the daytime running light
eyebrow which will be a new brand
signature it's another immediate sign of
a mercedes in addition to the grill
these eyebrows give the car a very
distinguished look
for line
bs class is the first vehicle in history
to replace all light bulbs with leds it
has almost 500 for lighting up the road
as well as the interior
the front passenger seat can be reclined
forward electrically to provide more
legroom behind
the rear seats offer their occupants a
choice of seven massage programs
normally
and his fellow journalists argue over
who gets to drive first today it's the
opposite everyone wanted to sit in the
back and it's a great ride he assures us
he has an incredible amount of leg room
that's in the long version of course he
also has fantastic headroom and home
comforts like this lovely pillow
so does he have any gripes at all
jens did his utmost to find one and
eventually did the car has 20 plus
assist systems but he still had to start
the engine using a key
you